hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we are in
game three of our coverage of the 2021
world chess championships between the
defending champion magnus carlson and
the challenger jan nepo now the first
two games were both drawls but they were
exciting you could tell both players are
trying some pretty creative things
they're definitely going for some
variations that are not easy
at all to play and so you know we'll see
uh this is the best of 14 series does
not look like these players just want to
play 14 straight draws although we do
have two draws so far so we'll see if
that changes
today and see if any of the tactics that
these players had in the first two days
will actually change today so white's
gonna be played by nepo today madness
crosston defending with the black pieces
starts out very similar to how we saw
game one when jan was playing the white
pieces starts out e4 e5 and then f3
knight c6 bishop b5 getting into the rye
lopez and similar to game one we see a6
bishop coming back here to a four
knight to f6
and similar moves all the way until we
get to move number eight so these all
should look very familiar if you've been
following our coverage and so usually
you you start to look at the
the marshall lines just looking at the
c3 preparing to push forward with d4
and then you have the anti-martial lines
and that's exactly what nepo was going
for in game number one he played pawn to
h3
in this game he decides to go for
a
four madness crosstram responds with
bishop here to b7
pawn to d3
d6 knight to d2 preparing to come down
here to f1 and then eventually come up
to
e3 it's sort of awkward if the knight
comes to c3 really want to have uh this
pawn being able to push forward up here
to c4 in the variation so knight coming
here to d2
then f1 position here to e3 allows it to
come to these great outposts here on f5
and d5 so that's what yon is thinking
about right now and then madison
crosston plays rook to e8 now this is a
move that many many moons ago you know
100 plus years ago this was pretty
common
not so much anymore we typically don't
see this nowadays you're looking at
things like knight two d7 just trying to
position this knight over to
the queen side of the board maybe now
knight 2f1 as we talked about and then
knight to
c5 attacking this bishop right here
centralizing this knight with an outpost
uh they asked amanda's crosston about
this rook here to e8 and he said yes
this was only the tenth move but this
was an awful move by him i think that's
kind of a stretch i don't know this
necessarily was awful uh but he did not
think very highly of this rook 2 e8
nepo now positions his knight here on f1
preparing to bring it to e3 as we talked
about hx just blocking off the g5 square
so the knight can't come here to g5 so
this knight on f3 it's going to be
hanging out not doing anything too much
bishop here to d2 bishop coming back
here to f8 just opening up for the rook
to control
this e-file
knight 2 e3 knight over here to e7 and
then c4 so
immediately once this knight moves away
from controlling this center of the
board uh jan decides to go ahead and
attack immediately on the queen side
with pawn up here to c4 do see the pawn
take knight take here on c4
knight c6 rook here to c1 just attacking
this semi open file here you always want
to put your rooks on semi-open files
meaning just one pawn is gone or an open
file if there's no pawns at all
rooks do really really well in that
position just because they can control
so much more of the board than just
defending right behind one pawn or piece
pawn comes down here to
a5 from madness carlson this is somewhat
of a tough spot i think this knight here
on c4 and the bishop on d2 are both
attacking it yes right now madness does
have both the knight here on c6 and the
rook here on a boat defending this pawn
uh but he's really just setting himself
up to have to
have multiple pieces trying to defend
this pawn here on a5 bishop to c3 bishop
comes back here to c8 pawn to
d4 we do see the exchange in this room
the board knight takes on d4 and then
the knight exchanges here on d4
definitely better i think than if you
want to try something else you know
bishop to b7 uh if you don't want to
take here
it gets pretty tricky because then all
of a sudden knight takes here on c6
bishop takes here
but then they can play f3 so defending
this pawn right here but now that knight
was defending this pawn here on a5 and
now white has both the bishop and the
knight attacking this it's gonna be very
difficult for black to hold on to this
pawn and so they're not so maybe
something like bishop to d7 and then the
knight takes here on a5 white would go
up a pawn in material so
think about this specific position
because in the game we see magnus take
here on d4 and then the queen takes and
then bishop here to e6 you may say okay
well now that that knight's gone
can't white actually just take
this pawn here on a5 and
if you look at it it's different because
the bishop here on e6 what magnus
carlsen is thinking this entire time is
this is actually defending this pawn
here on a5 and so you have to kind of
think about chess at a madness carlson
type level because you have to think
about if this knight moves what is it
leaving behind well it's leaving this
bishop here on b3 behind so if you see
the knight take here on a5
then c5 forcing the queen to come back
queen comes back here to d2 and then the
bishop takes here on
b3 so yeah they could play you know
knight takes here but then the knight
takes here on e4 and now black goes up
uh a good bit as far as development here
they can easily look to attack this pawn
here on a4 both sides equal in material
but it's going to be very easy i think
for black in this position to get the
upper hand this knight is attacking this
queen right now going to be looking to
take this pawn on the next move so all
in all definitely not the position
that white would want to be in and so
that's exactly why you see after bishop
here to e6 we don't see nepo taking the
pawn here on a5 instead we see pawn to
h3 something that he played very early
on in game one decides to go ahead and
play it
now
keeping the knights at bay so it doesn't
come over here to g4 just a nice little
move also allows the king at some point
to come to h2 doesn't have to worry
about any shenanigans on this first rank
here any sort of back rank mate anything
like that now pawn to c6
you usually don't just want to push up
here with c5 you want to have some
flexibility potentially now you could
play d5 if you just commit already with
pawn to c5 then all of a sudden you have
to worry about this backward pawn here
on d6 that you're gonna have to defend
the rest of the game here so uh c6 this
also opens up for the queen on d8 to now
defend this pawn here on a5 so it's
doing double duty anytime these players
are moving a piece they're always
thinking about multiple threats and
multiple ways they can defend with every
single move that's exactly what magnus
carlsen is doing with that c6 move now
bishop comes back to c2 putting another
defender on this e
4 square
pawn 2 d5 so does decide to go ahead and
attack on this d5 central light square
here pawn pushes forward to e5 attacking
of the knight we do see an exchange with
the pawn taking the knight queen takes
here up on d8
and then the pawn takes the knight here
and you can see just a flurry of uh
pieces coming off the board here and at
the end of it all
you can see magnus carlsen i think gets
the worst of it he has double pawns here
on the c file
going into the endgame not exactly what
he wants the bishops are on the same
color so it's going to be very difficult
for either of them to get the advantage
with just the bishops
and then you can start to see from the
rook coming over here to b8 and then
rook to b1 almost kind of seems like
they're looking to
get into a in game a drawn game just
because they are just moving the pieces
off the board here so after the rooks
came off i definitely knew this was
going uh to be a quick game after this
now we're on move 32 right now but it's
very difficult even though madness
carlson has uh the worst pawn structure
uh for yanepo to really do anything and
i would almost say this is an even
position i'd say white has a better uh
position in general but he's playing
magnus carlsen and so even though manus
carlson has a double pawn here on the c
file uh he is magnus so all in all i'd
say this is pretty even uh
if you take into account the players
that are playing the positions
so magnus doing a good job of
centralizing his king here uh now we see
yamapa doing the same thing king to e2
pawn f5 bishop here to c2 uh defending
the pawn over here on a4
uh bishop comes back here again not real
uh threat for any side here bishop to c2
just moving back and forth here bishop
to d7 attacking the pawn but the bishop
on c2 is gonna do a good job of
defending that pawn to f3
king comes back here to
f6 and the way these pawn structures are
set up there's there's no real way for
either of the kings uh to even push
through as well if pawns are on the c
and the f file you can see that
blockades all of the squares of going
towards the other side
same both for white and for black and
you can see
with just the b file as well as the g
file it's very difficult for either side
as well pawn here 2 h4 blocks off one of
the potential squares that the king can
come here to
g5 so magnus carlton just plays king 2
e5
king 2 f2 recognizing the only way
potential to get anywhere is on the king
side but this pawn here on f4 and it's
also on a dark square so the light
square bishop can't do anything about it
is going to prove very very difficult
for
yon to do anything about it so a few
moves later they have two-fold
repetition and then decide hey
this is going to be a draw game
and so they stopped after move
41. so this is game number three we have
three draws in a row i felt like the
first two were a little bit more dynamic
i was surprised that yon decided to play
the same ry lopez anti-martial i know he
played a4 instead of h3
on the eighth move
uh but i didn't feel like he had a
strong advantage in game one and my
takeaway from him playing the same
opening is he saw a weakness in magnus
carlsen i thought magnus was completely
prepared for that uh opening but all in
all it is what it is so we will have a
rest day tomorrow remember they have
three days on take a rest day come back
for two days take a rest day and they
receive that they repeat that same
process so another three days from there
take it off and then two days so uh we
will take a break tomorrow and then we
will be back
for two days after that so thank you
guys so much for watching three draws
we'll see if we can get some wins on the
board after the rest day but thanks for
watching i'll see you guys in the next
video
you